basically I was just getting a drink at
the bar and they called both a and I
ladies after they were done making the
drink I went up they I was like some
people don't refer to themselves as
ladies but it's okay that you didn't
know when a gay bar so we should feel
safe to that turned it around they got
so mad at me and they took the drink
away from my wife and I and he's told me
I'm being a gentleman calling you a lady
that's not something bad like I'm just
sharing that part and I just wanted you
to be like okay sorry what would you
like what would you like to hear I tried
talking to the other person he came over
and was like what's going on it was
another straight white man when I told
him he's just not respecting our
identity and I don't understand why and
he was like you know what just leave and
I got kicked out of a bar I didn't think
that was going to happen like how am I
supposed to feel this was the first time
that I've like told somebody I felt
brave enough to tell somebody my
identity and I just wanted to let him
know and I told him it's okay that you
didn't know he was still mad at me for
being myself and for my wife being
thems just
hurt with jenzie there's absolutely
no idea in how to Fathom your identity
beyond that of it being a political
statement
and being something that other people
have to recognize and other people have
to do something about they have to
change their actions in relation to how
you identify and you should be able to
engage with the world and walk in the
world safely securely and in the exact
way that you envisage and see um and
ultimately have no responsibility so the
world just to translate what you're
saying into so that I understand it
better simpler language what you're
saying is essentially people people
carry an idea of how the world is
supposed to adjust to them yes yes as
opposed to but
isn't I I understand how stup that is at
an intellectual level but at a practical
level are you not going to be slapped in
the face by reality on a daily basis if
you attempt to do this yes you are and
that's why I think a lot of people
Retreat to the internet and especially
in my
generation uh Because the Internet
allows you to live in the delusion that
the world can change and also it means
that when you go into the world and it
doesn't conformed to what you want it to
be you get very depressed mental health
issues arise um everything seems a lot
worse than it actually is and I
definitely see that as uh a big problem
with my
generation everything is a lot worse
than it is about things that actually
are not as important as the things that
actually are a
problem the thing with the victimhood
mindset I guess I can just call it is
that usually you find some kind of power
in it because people recognize your
victimhood and you find a community or a
tribe and then you know you feel good
about yourselves I didn't find that
Community because I wasn't accepted by
the black people that I was meant to be
tribal Allegiance with and that was very
reminiscent of my experience back in
South Africa and so I think because I
didn't find the kind of very
fake uh emancipation through being a
victim that most people who rarely
subscribe to a do I wasn't getting that
cathartic feeling from it and I think
the sort of really important thing was
that I applied to Oxford to do an Ma and
I didn't think about the logistics of it
I didn't think that I had to somehow
have £60,000 to do an Ma I thought it
was just going to happen because I was
black and so
obviously I'm not even kidding um I did
I really did
um I I couldn't fathom how it wasn't
going to happen I thought it was going
to happen I think cuz I was very deluded
as an undergraduate that I'd made it to
Cambridge I got in then I had this whole
idea of being a victim and so I was like
oh that's why I got in because you know
they needed to fill quotas and you know
it was like that and so obviously Oxford
was going to accept me and then pay for
me they accepted me but didn't pay for
me so suddenly I couldn't go and I had
no plans at all because my entire
mindset was I'm going to be an academic
I'm just going to be a political
philosopher that's all I'm going to do
and lo and behold uh the world doesn't
work like that and so I was alone I had
no money I didn't know what to do I had
no plans and I was applying for jobs
everywhere obviously I'd done no work
experience while I was at Uni cuz you
know you were going to be a political
philosopher exctly you know so um yes
and the only job I got was uh working at
a grocery store in Cambridge and so I
spent a few years there and that was
very important for me especially living
in Cambridge not as a student but as
somebody with the Cambridge working
class all of whom were white as well
which was very um I had to really
introspect about my oppression
um and um they didn't care that I'd gone
to Cambridge and I had to work to
actually get recognition to actually
Advance um not that I Advanced very far
uh I wasn't terribly good at my job
mainly just socialize with people but it
was very good because I made so many
friends work friends with people who
were mainly white
conservative uh gen xers uh who I worked
with and they became like my default
family and it was very important for me
to actually see that and to experience
the reality of people who live in
Cambridge who aren't like Rich students
cycling around everywhere thinking that
they rule the world and that really got
me out of not just myself but out of my
depression
definitely